the health sections i think they tend to
show things in terms of relative risk
which means they get to show more
interesting graphics i guess like you
know if you're showing how much you're
changing the risk over the general
population you could meet you know
showing a graph maybe with like this
genotype changes it this much this one
changes at this much and this intention
to this much that's more interesting
shape sort of see this big change it
looks like but if you look at that in
absolute terms it's actually that you
know your population risk is this much
and with the genotype change it's like
as much it's basically a sack and the
other side although slightly elevated
and so that's a less interesting picture
and so they think that's reasonable that
they choose to show us relative risk
it's just important that that the people
who are looking at these interpretations
understand what that means and that even
though it looks like a big change in the
graph it could be representing a very
small sort of absolute change in their
risk to this particular disease
you